men and women are not equal I know  everybody wants to think we are but  we're not and that's okay we're Polar  Opposites the man is supposed to be  strong he's supposed to go out and  provide and Conquer and the woman is  supposed to be emotional and soft and  that's okay she's supposed to lean on  the man so that way she can raise the  children better right now there's a  massive war in the family unit they're  trying to flip these beautiful gender  roles so that men and women don't  procreate because if he's all in his  feelings and he's emotional  unfortunately she's going to be repulsed  by him and if she's all masculine in her  male energy he's going to be repulsed by  her so they start rejecting each other  not producing the next generation of  children so we have two population  easiest to control a nation with less  people